in real life when you get hit
you either take the beating or you fight
back when you get hit in anime
you put a quick transformation that
ascends you in the power hierarchy and
then start punching back with arms
wrapped in plot armor with nearly two
decades of anime material i decided to
select 10 of the most epic main
character transformations in anime
history and by
epic i mean it either changes the course
of the main character or story
either in a good way or a bad way before
moving on make sure to subscribe to our
channel for more content like this
because there's a lot more content
coming your way with that said here
comes the 10 most epic anime mc
transformations of all time
[Music]
starting off our list we have the
transformation of ken kaneki
in tokyo ghoul route a tokyo ghoul's
second season was a rocky mess that
loosely adapted the manga according to
the producers wishes but at least they
were smart enough to include the most
integral scenes in all their glory
this transformation hits the tv screen
when kaneki is triggered by his sense of
cannibalism
and of course the hidden presence of
rize inside his conscience
the sight of the corpses awakened
kaneki's kakuja and unlike his previous
transformations this wasn't a pretty
sight the depressed white haired man
character suddenly seemed to lose all
sense of identity and morality as he
transformed into a human killing
centipede
you thought the one eyed owl was a great
threat unleash this form of kaneki to
the battleground and see what a powerful
ghoul's capable of armon's words
resonated with him before he broke down
crying but the damage was done
and his actions were irredeemable
next up we have shinji's transformation
from a lonely introvert to an
overpowered god
in neon genesis evangelion 2.0 this
movie's title was
you can not advance but ironically the
weakest character in the series
transformed into a weapon of destruction
during the movie's climax
what's the cause of this transformation
love of course in the final part of the
movie
things were desperate and speaking in
terms of evangelion you should know
desperate means absolutely and utterly
messed up in a way of no recovery oscar
is dead
nerve is on the brink of collapse and
rey is almost gone so it's time for
shinji to advance
his emotions for ray triggers the power
inside the eva
and rising up once again he breaks the
barriers of the angel to save rey who's
trapped inside the sequence was
tragically beautiful the sad and
depressing music in the background the
colour schemes and anno symbolism
splattered everywhere i'd like to say
that this transformation
was the best scene of the whole movie
needless to say our gear is one of the
best action anime movies of all time it
was like the big budget hollywood
blockbuster for anime back in the day
and the movie's writing and direction
obviously lay an impact on many modern
anime
and one scene that inspired many is the
transformation of tetsuo and you know
what makes this transformation unique
compared to many others on this list
this actually resulted in destroying the
world
rather than helping the main character
take down the bad guys to be honest
tensorflow's powers seem more of a
burden rather than an asset for him in
battle when he finds the remains of
akira under neo tokyo's olympic stadium
tetsuo loses control of his power until
he transforms into a mutated mass of
flesh
it's not the prettiest transformation i
know but when this transformation nearly
destroys the city and helps tetsuo
ascend to the plain of gods
you still have to call this epic
next up we have akira's transformation
in devilman crybaby
okay now don't confuse the two akiras
one was an esper and the other here is a
devil no not the average demon lord you
see in most power fantasy shows these
days but a half human
half devil with his devil counterpart
being the strongest in the world netflix
seems to have learned its lesson from
adapting live-action adaptations so to
make sure the anime fans would have
murdered them alive
they gave it their best to devilman
crybaby and the most integral part of
the first episode
came as a transformation amon devouring
akira in a blood-bathed nightclub wasn't
the most epic scene anyone could think
of but the devil that came afterwards
sent
chills down our spine combine that
rotoscope animation with the crybaby
soundtrack and
oh boy that's when we knew what sort of
a wild ride netflix had planned for us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
coming up next is luffy's gear fourth
transformation in one piece
one thing i love about one piece is that
ajiro order knows how to use a unique
power in an interesting way
this transformation relies on the power
of elasticity and compression of the
devil fruit and by creating more
pressure within his muscles
luffy is able to compress the power
using armament haki to the outside he
might look like a jumping rubber ball
but you have to wait till he starts the
punching similar to gear 3 before the
time skip the gear 4 transformation
takes a lot of energy from luffy so
he'll have to do
maximum damage to his opponents within a
few seconds but
needless to say when you've got high
pressure rubber arms that's enough to
snap an average man's body after just
one punch
[Music]
next up is the transformation of naruto
during his fight with pain
during the pain arc pain was all that
naruto got his sensei was killed his
village was destroyed
and hinata was brought down to her knees
right in front of his eyes
just after she made her confession so
it's no wonder that this boy
literally called his inner demon to do
the rest of the job for him
naruto had gotten various power-ups
every now and then but the pain fight
was what showcased what the nine-tailed
fox was capable of
even while keeping seven of its nine
tails love or hate the animation
all that we should know is payne learned
his lesson by fleeing
getting hammered to the ground and even
being thrown into a mountain
horizontally until his legs stuck
out thankfully fourth hokage stepped
into the game and calmed down his angry
son
or naruto shippuden's episode count
would have been way
[Music]
lower
coming up next is our shinigami taking
things to the next level when ichigo
transforms into avasto lord
in bleach okay let's admit it ichigo
took his fair share of beatings in the
first few arcs of the anime thus the
writing had to survive through a pretty
basic formula
the bad guy kicks ichigo's ass and he
pulls up a power-up and uses the uno
reverse card
in this case it was his second round
against okiyora and he desperately
needed a power-up to take down this
espada
turns out orihime's words may be the
trigger in this case
they say screams of love can bring you
back from the dead but ichigo
literally proves this by awakening in
his new form with the resolve to protect
orihime
the next stuff that happened well no
surprise there a white-faced espada
learned the lesson of underestimating
random people who tried to attack the
aran car
in terms of character design i like to
say this is ichigo's coolest
transformation to date
[Music]
coming in at number three is goku's
ultra instinct
in dragon ball at times even i was
surprised how this show went from
simple martial arts to fights between
gods but hey with each transition we got
a new transformation
goku's ultra instinct separates his
conscience from his body
giving him more flexibility and agility
while using skills of martial art combat
needless to say this isn't what you
would achieve in your yoga meditation
session
since it's difficult to master the one
who masters it would get the power to
swat down even the most powerful gods in
the universe
and this time the guy to earn that swot
was a member of the pride troopers
jiren was considered as one of the
strongest mortals in the multiverse but
needless to say
he wasn't the main character of the show
so it was time to take a back seat it
was sad to see goku lose his power due
to the forms in perfect state but let's
give the guy
a position on our list because this is
about epic transformations
and not about victories
isn't the only one who was awarded with
a transformation because of pain
the literal pain i mean because you've
got that one level higher with the
transformation of
gone kind's death triggered all the
guilt and sorrow gone's been hiding
inside him and these personified by
transforming gone into a more adult self
in truth this was because of the massive
amounts of men stored in gohan's body
and when all the stored energy was
released
it wasn't something pretty gone's
unstable mind made a contract as his
conscience had completely broken down
and the ultimate price was paid his life
force itself his future
and all his potential pito learned what
every anime villain learned over time
never to underestimate main characters
who can pull a power up and he learned
this the hard way
and by hard way i mean getting kicked up
to the sky and then being punched with
an immensely powerful punch the downside
of this transformation is that it could
have resulted in guns near death
hunter hunt is known for its unique
power system with the give and take
philosophy so it's not a surprise that
gone had to survive a long time in a
hospital bed as a repercussion
foreign
attack on titan's known for its twist
and i made a whole video to prove that
point
but who thought that the annoying main
hero of the first season would turn out
to be the villain
aaron pulls up a transformation one
notch lower from tetsuo
as he doesn't destroy the world but
massacres an entire city
we all knew it was aaron when the anime
started giving more screen time to the
hobo in the mental hospital but let's
admit that rhino was the most surprised
when his good old friend came to say
hello but this handshake wasn't a
friendly greeting because as one aldian
declared war on parodies
another ldm brought that war right into
the main city as he brutally went on a
killing spree in search of the warhammer
titan with the anime taking a drastic
turn
you can surely expect a wild ride from
this season and since this
transformation resulted in turning a man
vs monster show into one of the best
anime storylines ever told
this definitely deserves the number one
spot on our list
so there goes my favorite 10 epic mc
transformations do you agree with this
list or is there something that i missed
don't be afraid to raise your voice in
the comments if you enjoyed the video
leave a like
and if you aren't a regular watcher of
our channel then make sure to subscribe
for more anime content like this
with that said we're done with today's
content anime fans i'll be seeing you in
the next video